Hôm Ánh hả tính vừa chịp phá đường dây sản xuất, muôn bán gạo ra nhắn hiệu của công ty chách nghiệm hiệu hả,
thu dữ gần năng tính gạo ra, khởi tổ một bị cân với tội dành, sản xuất muôn bán hàng ra đã lương thực.
Lối thực là phạm văn phụng, xinh năm 1 miến chính trong bệm tư, chú tại phương thành xen tình hả tính đã thực hiện hàng vi đống gói,
sản xuất thạo ra nhắn hiệu của công ty chách nghiệm hiệu hảnh gói.
Lực lượng trước năng thu dữ 2-55 tính gạo, được đống trong 2-55 bảo bị ra,
in thông tin nhắn hiệu thơm lại sữa, cỏng ai chất lượng thay lời nói, và chỉ giãn địa lĩnh lời sản xuất của công ty chách nghiệm rữ hảnh gói,
để chỉ tại tình đồng thấp. Đối thực hùng khai nhận, đả mua gạo xúc xèu giả dẻ,
muôn gốc chơi nổi trên thị trường, sau đó sự dụng bảo bị ra nhắn hiệu thơm lại sữa để đống gói bán cho chình kim thơ,
cùng chú tại hả tính, với giá mởi bá chự động một tính, dàng thú lợi nó chính.
Tổng khối lượng gạo xả phạm văn phụng đã bán cho chình kim thơ, là muốn phải mấy mấy tám tính.
Hoài ra, lối thực còn khai nhận đả thư thủ sủ lượng lượng gạo xả măng nhắn hiệu khác,
cho nhiều cã nhân, cơ sở kinh sôn trên địa bản tình hả tính.